W tym rozdziale zbadamy
jak komputery kwantowe i klasyczne
współpracują, by rozwiązać jedno z najważniejszych wyzwań
w nauce — dokładne szacowanie energii cząsteczek i materiałów
Możemy to osiągnąć
używając quantum circuit
do generowania próbek przykładów
które następnie poddamy post-processingowi
i diagonalizacji za pomocą różnych algorytmów
z tej rodziny procedur
takich jak SQV, SKG — a na platformie
IBM Quantum jest cały kurs
poświęcony im i pokrewnym metodom
Na nasze potrzeby w tej sekcji
ograniczymy wyjaśnienie do minimum
Niezależnie od tego, czy używasz SQV czy SKG
twoim celem jest znalezienie wektorów własnych
i wartości własnych macierzy hamiltonianu
Ta macierz może opisywać energię układu fizycznego
lub chemicznego, ale ten sam framework
pozwala rozwiązywać wiele innych typów problemów
jak choćby logistykę. Czasem
te macierze są ogromne
więc zredukowanie wymiarów
macierzy przy zachowaniu ważnych
cech stanu podstawowego
może być niezwykle wartościowe — to właśnie cel SQV
Używamy komputera kwantowego, by wygenerować użyteczną podprzestrzeń
taką, która zawiera stan podstawowy
Możemy wtedy rzutować macierz hamiltonianu
na tę podprzestrzeń, co daje nam
małą macierz, którą będzie
o wiele łatwiej diagonalizować
klasycznym obliczeniami wysokiej wydajności. Robimy to
przygotowując próbny stan kwantowy
często zwany ansatzem
i wykonując pomiary w celu próbkowania tego ansatza
w bazie obliczeniowej. To daje nam
podprzestrzeń próbek w bazie obliczeniowej
ale tak naprawdę chcemy znaleźć
prawdziwy stan podstawowy. Co
jeśli nasza podprzestrzeń próbek nie zawierała
wszystkich niezbędnych składowych?
Gdybyśmy wybrali lepszy ansatz
moglibyśmy uzyskać lepsze oszacowanie stanu podstawowego
To prowadzi nas do sample-based
Krylov quantum diagonalization, czyli SKQD. W SKQD
zaczynamy od ansatza
jak poprzednio, ale potem stosujemy kilka quantum gates przybliżających
ewolucję czasową układu fizycznego
Można pokazać, że przy kilku założeniach
prowadzi to do gwarancji na pokrywanie się ewolucji czasowej
ansatza z prawdziwym stanem podstawowym
Oba te algorytmy zaczynają od ogromnych
macierzy hamiltonianu. Działają nieco inaczej
ale w obu przypadkach kwantowa część algorytmu daje
podprzestrzeń pozwalającą nam zmniejszyć macierz
z nadzieją zachowania kluczowych cech stanu podstawowego
Gdzie więc pojawia się klasyczne obliczenie wysokiej wydajności?
W przypadku największych hamiltonianów
i dla najbardziej dokładnych oszacowań stanu podstawowego
nawet te zrzutowane macierze mogą być całkiem duże
Dlatego wykorzystanie mocniejszych możliwości klasycznych komputerów
może nam pomóc nie tylko
uzyskać lepsze wyniki
ale też pozwalając nam rozwiązywać większe problemy
Żeby to wszystko połączyć
możemy reprezentować algorytmy sample-based
jako kombinację różnych modeli programowania
na zestawie zasobów heterogenicznych
Na przykład możemy reprezentować nasz algorytm
jako przepływ zadań, gdzie mamy zadanie
przygotowania quantum circuit pokrywającego się
z naszym stanem docelowym, po którym następuje zadanie
transpilacji wymagającego tylko zasobów klasycznych
do wykonania. Następne będzie zadanie
używające prymitywów do uruchomienia naszego quantum circuit
co oczywiście
a potem mamy zadanie post-processingu, które samo w sobie
może być równoległym algorytmem diagonalizacji
działającym na wielu węzłach
Dodatkowo możemy chcieć uruchamiać
jeden z tych algorytmów wielokrotnie
podczas gdy zmieniamy nasz ansatz
albo uruchamiać je całkowicie równolegle
z różnymi populacjami
Teraz złączmy to wszystko z SKQD
w kodzie. Oto wszystkie nasze pliki zadań
a tu wszystkie nasze pliki zgłoszeń
W zadaniu mapowania przygotowujemy circuits.
W kroku optymalizacji uruchamiamy circuits w najlepszy sposób.
W zadaniu wykonania próbkujemy bity
ze stanu przygotowanego przez
nasz ISA circuit.
Który dostajemy z poprzedniego kroku
i wykonujemy post-processing.
Jesteśmy więc gotowi, żeby przesłać nasz
przepływ pracy.
Jak widać, wszystko jest zapisane w sekwencji
z zależnościami. Poczekajmy
na wyniki i możemy sprawdzić nasze pliki wyjściowe.
Tu jest otwarty plik z kroku optymalizacji
gdzie mamy nasz ISA circuit.
Sprawdźmy w końcu nasz wynik
iteracji.
Z harmonogramu.
I to tyle w ramach krótkiej demonstracji przepływu pracy SKQD
Cały kod będzie dostępny w sekcji tekstowej
lub w opisie poniżej
I to na tyle — przeszliśmy teraz przez kilka
konceptów i przykładów, które pomogą ci zacząć pracę z
zarządzaniem złożonymi hybrydowymi programami. Oczywiście
to tylko zarysowuje powierzchnię
wszystkiego, co można zrobić łącząc kwantowe
i klasyczne zasoby obliczeniowe. Żeby dowiedzieć się więcej
zajrzyj do dokumentacji i tutoriali
na platformie IBM Quantum
i koniecznie sprawdź zasoby podane w sekcji tekstowej
lub opisie, po więcej materiałów
i oprogramowania. Dzięki za oglądanie.
No to tak.